princess charlene of monaco is
temporarily stepping down from official
duties while she seeks treatment in a
facility just outside the country in a
new interview with people her husband
prince albert ii of monaco reveals that
the 43 year old princess is suffering
profound quote exhaustion both emotional
and physical the decision to seek
medical care comes just days after her
return home to monaco the princess
previously spent six months in south
africa due to an ear nose and throat
infection which involved a number of
corrective surgeries resulting in an
extended stay we are finally back it's
been a while one week after sharing a
photo of her happy reunion with husband
albert and their six-year-old twins
charlene announced she was pulling out
of monaco's national day festivities on
november 19th citing profound general
fatigue with ongoing rumors that the
couple is going through marriage
troubles prince albert clarifies quote
this has nothing to do with our
relationship i want to make that clear
it's of a different nature he goes on to
say that her current state is the result
of several factors which are private
matters adding quote she was clearly
exhausted physically and emotionally she
was overwhelmed and couldn't face
official duties life in general or even
family life
the prince also dispels rumors that
charlene's treatment is for covid or
cancer he also shuts down speculation of
plastic surgery albert adds that
charlene agreed to seek treatment after
he conducted an intervention with her
brothers and sister-in-law noting that
she had already made her decision and
that they only wanted her to confirm it
in front of them quote she wanted this
she already knew the best thing to do
was to go and have a rest and have a
real medically framed treatment as for
how the family will handle the
separation well albert is looking for
love and support from those around him
including the people of monaco